there's a crisis at our southern border
the administration won't call it that
but fox news has got an exclusive uh
peek at some of the numbers and at least
160 000 migrants have been released into
the country since march now what's
interesting the first number at the top
close to 32 000 were released via parole
now that's a new one for for us right
that means they get legal some form of
legal status and the ability to work
right and but here's the thing easily it
is granted parole is granted on a
case-by-case basis for urgent
humanitarian purposes rodney scott who's
the former border patrol chief said you
know under biden when i was uh in charge
of that i probably gave out five or ten
total
per year instead the bite administration
close to 32 000 they found a loophole to
let a whole bunch of people he said he
thinks the administration's abusing its
parole authority yeah listen to 94 570
they were giving a notice to report uh
that means that they just have to notify
the ice office whenever they get to
where they're going their final
destination
there's no legal obligation they don't
actually have to do it right 39 630
released on their own recognizance since
august 6 6 obviously they don't have a
number on the godaways or else they
would have gotten them and probably put
them under one of these categories right
uh but this is pretty unbelievable see
what you have is an administration where
does regardless of administration the
men and women of border patrol and texas
national guard they got to do the same
job and they know it works what doesn't
work and the reason why we're getting
the numbers is because these people
don't run for office they're just trying
to control the country's borders right
as an admirable patriotic thing to do
this administration has no interest in
doing it in fact now we have a new new
thing happening we got middle-class
people from other countries deciding i'm
not even going to apply right to come
here in ibiza i'm going to walk through
the border and according to lindsey
graham end up in connecticut with my
gucci bag and trying to live a middle
class life in another country because we
have no process well there's an article
this morning in the wall street journal
which is co-owned with our company uh
you know there are 26 million people
lost their jobs in south america and the
caribbean islands and that's why we've
we're seeing so many people that's a 26
million in the last year and so what a
lot of middle class
people in south america are doing is
they're taking a flight
to
mexico as close to the us border as they
can and then they're either getting into
a taxi or a bus and they're going right
up to the border they'll drop them off
right there and then they walk across
and then they then they just start
looking hey who can i surrender to chris
why would i go to ellis island
chris clem the chief u.s border patrol
agent in yuma arizona said this to the
wall street journal they got off the
plane and they went to a cab or two a
bus they literally were driven up and
just walked up and turned themselves
over to us well if they can do it
couldn't people who are trying to come
into our country for instance for bad
purposes like terrorists and something
like that do exactly the same thing the
answer is yes especially after the
taliban take over in afghanistan oh yeah
i mean listen we were saying for the
long time why would anyone do it the
right way now no one's doing it the
right way fox and friends enterprise
reporter lawrence jones is on the ground
with more than 30 migrants when they
were caught on a rancher's private
property yesterday lawrence is live in
bracketville texas and he joins us now
hey lawrence
hey good morning family it was an
interesting day yesterday i had the
opportunity to spend the day with the
texas department of public safety
special operations
division
what we saw was incredible take a look
about 30 migrants illegal migrants on
your property
this is the first time this ever
happened oh no sir this happens
daily and weekly
it slowed down for a little bit maybe
two or three weeks ago but now it's on
the surge is back again i'll tell you
that's what troubles in
it was slow out here i never saw a board
tour made once a week
you know with dps was our blessing this
summer
and now they're here to still help but
we can't allow them to do that they
weren't allowed to arrest these folks
today how do you feel about that oh i'm
i'm upset i mean that just i mean that's
like a punch to the belly we can't get
the federal administration to allow us
to turn them back deep
so so what is the difference of the two
when dps arrests them they charge them
with criminal trespasses criminal
trespassing they go to jail and we can
slow it down when border patrol arrests
them they're going to release them back
into mexico correct and how long is it
going to take them to be back over here
i wouldn't be surprised if it's tomorrow
night when you have that revolving door
you know it will never stop the question
is now are they going to come and break
into my house or what are they going to
do are they going to come in
that runs through your mind oh that runs
through your mind all the time when
you're out here on the ranch do you
worry about your family's safety oh yeah
i always worry about my family safety
this is 32 right here they cost right
okay how many more
the got aways got a ways that they're
not talking about
two groups
they're just waiting for clearance to
get the drone up
oh yeah
i got runners is that them right there
[Music]
take the boy
out of texas
where did you come from sir i'm from
mexico city my friend from mexico city
yes and what made you come take this
journey sir i wanted to wish you my
family and kids say thank you so 28
years in united states i'm trying to go
back the government changed you know
donald trump and the new president
changed the rules and he comes from my
case
that's why i'm
i have to
try to go see my family you know
and what is your friend's story
my friend story he's my friend from
durham he's my wife
brother-in-law
he's no coyote he's not nothing no no no
nothing he's my friend
have you ever been arrested
no no said he got deported for uh no
driver's license do you have any idea
let's run through some of the criminal
bad
background this individual over here um
he's from durango mexico and he's been
arrested for possession of
methamphetamine and also illegal entry
league would be the charge for border
patrol correct this individual here has
been arrested for
multiple legal entries which are charges
from border patrol
which are deportation charges of death
and domestic violence which were here in
the united states are you trying to go
see that same wife
wife when you get here were you planning
on meeting up with this is the new
there's some this is another wife yeah
like where your kids
are as well
mike you got no kids with this woman
my girlfriend so now they're getting
ready to head to the detention center um
this is a part of operation lone star
essentially the property owners gave
troopers department of public safety
the permission to come on their property
they coordinated with them and once they
got a ding on some of the sensors
texas troopers were able to come out to
the scene and process them men and women
protecting the border work day and night
even flying over the southern border and
helicopters to be eyes in the sky for
those on the ground what not we got a
group of about a dozen right here don't
see any kids with them
but they're young
probably
he's maybe in his 30s he's probably his
20s there's movement there all right
they're on the move they're on the move
straight keep going north get going
there's about ten
two four six they're about 10.
they're heading uh closer to the opening
defender
all right we got the light on them
two o'clock
right in front of you there's your
picture of the group yeah here's a
picture part of the group there we go
hey guys and i just got some reaction
from the texas department of public
safety they have arrested about 1 200
migrants legally entering the country
since july i hope you guys caught that
one clip of the guy saying he had no
criminal background that he was only
deported under donald trump because of
his driver's license we later found out
after he gave us that sob story that he
did have a record for domestic violence
i'm gonna send it back to you guys in
new york well the one that was going to
look for his wife and his kids
that's exactly right he had a domestic
violence charge and that's why i asked
him i said are you going back to that
same wife he says no i got a new wife
okay
oh yeah a lot going on down there right
it's pretty amazing lawrence do you from
off the top of your head should the
texas
uh should the texas guard be doing this
troopers or is this something the border
patrol would normally be doing
they shouldn't be doing this but they
have no choice but to do this because a
lot of the texas residents are putting
pressure on the governor on their
elected leaders to do something and the
federal government is simply not doing
it i mean the border patrol they want to
be able to do their job but they're not
allowed to do the foot pursuit they're
not allowed to do what the texas
department of public safety is doing so
texans are have their back against the
wall and like i continue to say and i've
been saying this for the last three
weeks the last defense of the country
the last defense of texas is the texas
department of public safety right we
shouldn't be having to pay for this in
the state of texas well then you said
they were they were going to a detention
center what happens after that that
costs more money yeah so they'll be
charged they'll be charged with criminal
proc uh criminal trespass here in the
state of texas and then they'll go
through the legal uh channels there the
d.a will bring those charges um and and
that they'll go through the united
states process for that so yet to be
determined whether or not they are sent
back home to mexico or if they can stay
well they'll be turned over to border
patrol after they do that period of time
whatever the the process is for the
united states then border patrol picked
them up and the texas uh the the people
of texas are paying this bill right to
put them through the process
unbelievably right yeah that's exactly
right and we can show you the numbers
but to actually see it with your own two
eyes as you've been able to bring with
your cameras lawrence it's a yeah it was
great reports thank you